hey guys i'm ryan right hey what's up
I'm Veronica
hi Lauren gah so we're gonna adjust the
seating here so I'm not blocking you
dude we're gonna watch this we're gonna
actually watch a short film right now I
did a trailer reaction to a short film
recently called
catch and then I saw is available on
iTunes so I thought it'd be fun if we
just watched it and reviewed it really
fast the trailer and treat me it's about
a father and son playing catch or
something like that it's getting a lot
of great feedback David Henry directed
it you know that is you start you do
that's right you're wrong Wizards of
Waverly Place a few times with him
yeah you start with you Selena Gomez's
brother and Wizards of Waverly Place oh
yeah
apparently he's a very talented guy
actually who can do a lot more than
Disney like he's very talented actually
so I think he wrote and directed this
one he's not starring in it but still
father and son stories really get to me
a lot do you guys handle parents stories
well no I get really emotional and stuff
and I hear this is kind of a tearjerker
maybe yeah they're right over there okay
guys we're ready you got daddy issues we
all have daddy issues mm-hmm all right
let's check out this movie
well we just watched that so we just
watch that short film that was I didn't
know what to expect he just said that it
was about you know father-son playing
catch it was really sweet and really
heartwarming the one thing that I'm
going to say is that I feel like I've
heard that story before I thought that
it was beautifully written from the
perspective of this little boy that us
in this adult world we forget about what
it's like to be kid and we forget about
how we affect these children I mean I'm
not a parent but I have been a kid so I
think that it was it was beautiful great
quality
yeah great quality music it was an
original score I was deeply moved by it
obviously we just watched it and I am
embarrassed right now what is the name
of the boy James Jimmy Jeremy I swear
they said Jeremy will you please come to
the principal's office didn't they call
him James anyway yeah
the the acting I think is phenomenal
from this kid he he really brought it
and they did great with casting go young
very impressed with the casting in this
film yeah it's a short film I don't want
to give anything away because the short
film but there is this one moment where
the kid gets very emotional and that
[ __ ] had anybody really cheering up a
lot actually
yeah I'm afraid to keep talking about it
right now cuz I'm afraid to try again
alright definitely could relate to it
yeah it's very relatable
it's very relatable that's like going
off what you said about how you know
adults the difference in between the
world that we live in I guess I feel
like we really in between those two
worlds but growing up I feel like I was
really lucky to have parents that were
around and like I underst
like how hard it can be because it
happens a lot when there's fathers that
are trying to provide for their family
and like work so hard so that family can
have the best life that they can but
what they don't realize is that actually
being there and what yeah the most
important yeah like oh god a second
give me a second yeah you guys should
watch this short film now yeah like I
gotta remember Oh God
all right I remember I remember like my
dad he was really ill growing up so I
couldn't play like like everyone we
gotta play like sports with her dad and
stuff and I didn't get to
oh god it's weird out ten minutes can
really just get to you yeah I was
directed beautifully to like the way the
cinematography was all captured and
stuff and for a short film it's it's
powerfully effective for a 10-minute
piece well it's like 11 minutes or
something but it's very effective in the
sense that like there's not a whole lot
of dialogue there's just enough it moves
by fast and I love the way the story
builds where you're like what the hell's
this kid exactly doing you know he's
kind of being rebellious right now you
know when you find out what it's all
about it is like oh wow that's it hey
yeah I'm kind of having a hard time
finding words because all I can focus on
is how I feel right now we're at a time
right now in America where the economy
is like really tough it's just so many
people become so job focused and stuff
and then when you are successful you're
even more job focused to maintain that
success so to see that struggle and then
to see the like how it was affecting
their family the job it's like really is
this is all about this whole story is
just about family and now important
family it's about how you have to you do
have to like like what you said earlier
it is just about being there for your
it's a reality check a 10 11 minute
reality check like buy it I would say
buy I would say by meeting between what
was it the buyer yeah I buy it around 10
minutes you can watch it you know in a
snap I feel like if I was a parent and I
would want to buy it just so that if I
was getting to an in to work I would
just watch it and just like get get back
into what really matters what I really
loved about it - just on what filmmaking
perspective was how this could have
easily been something that was it could
have been really cheesy and really like
we really want you to cry but there's so
much life in it like there's some
enthusiasm there's some fun and like
there's a lot of different colors in
this film there's a lot of life in it
which makes that final moments even more
effective because the film's about life
yeah you really didn't get a lot of camp
I've never cried during a review before
fitness so we never seen Lauren cry like
16 times in the one time and I original
yeah like yeah I do agree with you in
this Lauren in the sense that like how
the story has been done before but it's
more about like it yeah the execution of
it was definitely different like the
execution was very authentic yeah I
would say definitely buy it on iTunes go
watch it right now
yeah watch it right now you got plenty
of time check it out you only need 10
minute check it out and this note but we
all have YouTube channels so yes goodbye
you can subscribe to the real rejects
here you can subscribe to Veronica right
here and you can subscribe to Lauren
right here so yeah you can check out all
our channels and yeah thanks for
stopping by